what is this
[Music]
god of war is a phenomenal game that
everyone should play no question and if
you're watching this video it's probably
safe to say that you're interested in
playing it too if you haven't already
started but if you really want to get
the most out of its stunning world then
it's fantastic and definitely not boring
combat then you should really consider
playing in immersive mode what are we
hunting you aren't a deer there's an
option in the game settings that lets
you toggle the game's HUD between normal
and immersive mode which removes the
game's meters compass icons and most of
its pop-ups god of War's hut is already
quite minimal which is great but after
finishing and playing the latter half of
the game in immersive mode let me tell
you this is the way to experience got a
wall the idea of no hut is always a
little daunting for sure but don't be
scared in this video I want to assure
you that it's totally viable by
explaining how you can pass the
information you need and explain why the
things you're missing out on aren't a
big deal first of all why do it and one
of the benefits of not getting every
single little detail of information well
on a superficial level God of War is a
very very very good-looking game
immersive mode makes sure the entirety
of your screen can be used to appreciate
the beauty of the environments the
character models and get the full impact
of the game's truly impressive
camerawork with that one along a 40 hour
Steadicam shot
[Music]
on a more substantial level being able
to pay full attention to the environment
without any distractions will help you
with your exploration you'll pay more
attention to the details in the
environment and you'll almost be
guaranteed to never miss out on a
collectible no alternate paths will go
unnoticed and no stray pot or wooden
item we'll go on smashed because you're
looking so keenly at the world instead
of an icon on a compass but more
importantly immersive mode will make you
better at that combat in action games
it's a common and completely logical
tendency to always keep one eye on
either your health meter your enemy's
health meter enemy location indicators
your skill cooldowns whatever but that's
one eye that's not actually watching the
fight immersive mode lets you focus
completely on using all of your skill to
be the best fighter you can be hit every
parry dodge every attack and take
advantage of every opening if you like
me and you know you have a full bar of
health you'll sometimes get a little
sloppier because you know craters can
take a few hits but why not perform at
your absolutely best all the damn time
you need to set a good example for a
tres after all is that enemy you're
fighting a purple enemy who's supposed
to be too overpowered for you who knows
and who cares if you can beat it then
what does it matter
immersive mode frees you from self-doubt
now I do recommend that on your first
playthrough you should definitely spend
the early hours with the default HUD
just save me a basic feel of how combat
operates especially how the stun
mechanic works but by the time you get
to the lake of nine in the game opens up
you should be good to go with immersive
there is one thing I've been keeping
from you that might make things a little
easier God of War also has a custom HUD
option which lets you toggle certain
elements on or off but best of all it
allows you to assign some HUD options to
the ps4's touch pad meaning you can turn
everything off but still take a brief
look at anything you want to with a
gentle tap of the touch pad so if you're
finding a mercy mode hard to get used to
at the beginning give the touch pad
stuff a try before going back to normal
all right so how do you actually manage
the information you need for combat with
that same bars or indicators well God of
War has a bunch of in-world cues that
make immersive mode accessible and tell
you literally everything you need to
know they're all pretty obvious as
you'll see but let's run through them
for peace of mind first of all if you've
been wailing on an enemy with light
attacks or your bare fists and see the
pulsing red circle around them it means
you can execute your takedown move not
being able to see how much stun you're
dealing to an enemy might seem like a
disadvantage especially against
revenants who have a rapid stun recovery
but all you need to know is that if
you're looking to stun someone you need
to really focus them and keep up the
pressure until you see that red dot
otherwise it's not gonna happen
regardless
[Music]
if the screen has a glowing red vignette
that means you're low on health that's a
pretty standard thing but in God of War
a trace will also tell you as much just
in case it wasn't obvious enough if the
screen is a glowing blue vignette it
means you've been affected by frost and
your attack speed will be slowed you'll
also see the blue iciness on cradles
poison and shock effects are also pretty
obvious except they're green and yellow
you honestly don't need a little icon in
the corner to tell you that you're
poisoned please you also don't need to
use the enemy in the care ring to know
when you're being blindsided just listen
carefully to at raius because he'll tell
you when you're being attacked and from
where you see what I mean all this stuff
is pretty straightforward and
pre-existing and it's all stuff you'll
likely be accustomed to by the time you
internalize the combat system but
alright I'm sure you have a bunch of
questions and concerns such as how do
you know when you need to heal obviously
it's a good idea to save green gems for
until you really need them and you know
that when a trace is yelling at you and
your screens turning red then you
probably need to find some health gems
pronto
now remember when I talked about
immersive mode giving you way more
awareness in combat I mean you'll likely
be avoiding more hits overall which
means you'll likely have more spare
health gems laying around and as you
spend more time at the game you should
organically get an idea of roughly how
many blows you can take before hitting
the red zone health management then
becomes more of a gut feeling kind of
thing for example if I enter a fight and
I know that I'm at full health and then
I take three or four hits from an enemy
I can be pretty sure that grabbing one
green gem will bring me back to full
health once the fight is over you'll
naturally want to pick up everything
that's on the battlefield and that
should put you in perfect shape to the
next encounter measuring cooldowns for
your runic weapon and talisman skills as
well as at races abilities is a little
clearer when an ability comes off
cooldown and is ready to use
there'll be a handy audible chime from
even the left or right of the screen
where the meters would normally be Trace
will say something like I'm set or tell
me when when his arrows are ready after
using them all up that said it is good
to keep in mind roughly how long the
cooldown on your chosen abilities are
which can be anywhere from thirty to
ninety seconds and keep a rough track of
when you use them now the tricky one
depending on your playstyle is knowing
when Spartan rage is ready to go
I typically only use Barton rage during
boss fights or particularly large mobs
but if you like to use it as soon as you
can as much as you can you might want to
use the custom touch pad HUD to
periodically check on the meters
all right so how about all that sweet
loot you're gonna find along your
journey an immersive mode most of the
white highlights you pick up off the
ground along with the stuff you find in
chests coffins and on the water
weren't activate a pop-up but seriously
don't sweat it's probably just in pack
silver a small XP boost or crafting
materials
none of these are things you need to
worry about immediately because let's
face it every time you come upon a
weapons store you're gonna check in and
see if you can craft or upgrade any new
gear anyway if you have the prerequisite
hack silver and crafting materials great
and if you don't well see you next time
with a mercy mode you'll likely be a lot
more aware of hidden paths and pickups
along the way so it's not like you're
gonna miss out on a whole mess of stuff
that's gonna stop you from upgrading
something because you probably wouldn't
have been able to do it anyway now if
you find significant items like new
runic attacks uncommon legendary or epic
gear legendary materials health apples
or meat horns a big pop up will come up
regardless because that's stuff that you
might find useful immediately and the
game knows that finally your compass god
of wars open areas are not so common
looted that you're gonna need to
constantly follow an objective market to
get where you need to go taking a glance
at your world map in the menu making a
note of your orientation and where your
next main or side objective might be and
then setting off in that general
direction allowing the natural pathways
and your perception of major landmarks
that guide you is usually enough to get
you where you need to be unfortunately
for those of you who are super into law
both the loot and lore pop-ups are
things that can't be toggled
individually in the custom HUD screen
and can't be it's time to the touchpad
menu you're either all in or all out so
you might need to make a decision here
based on how badly you want to read the
law immediately versus seeing pop-ups
that tell you've picked up like five
hacked silver every time you smash apart
alright that's a lot of words and time
spent to assure you that yes playing God
of War in immersive mode can be a
completely practical and good option
again it's something that I implore you
to do because it'll give you a greater
appreciation of just how well this game
environments are designed for exploring
how deep and exciting its combat can be
and just how stunning every facet of the
game is
I honestly wish I'd done it earlier so
turn on immersive mode in God of War
it's the best way to play
[Music]